[Music]
good morning John it's Tuesday June 5th
ah
that was nice Katherine and I have some
friends that have a cabin up on Seeley
Lake which is a really nice place and
Kathryn and I went there this week to
hang out it was awesome it was kind of
weird though for Kathryn because she was
like the only not pregnant girl babies
babies babies to me it does not feel
like baby time yet but a lot of my
friends are having baby time I'm worried
that if I ever have a baby
it won't have any friends because all of
the other babies will be so much older
than him
yes that's a pretty stupid fear unless
everybody stops having the capability of
having babies which I've read two books
about lately and seen one movie so maybe
it's not that far-fetched having read
those books and then seeing all these
pregnant people suddenly not so worried
speaking of books I just read feed in my
pants and everybody was right
I don't want Wikipedia in my brain I
don't want Wikipedia in my Brando at
Wikipedia and own Wikipedia in my brain
don't want a Wikipedia ring no one will
keep eating my brain oh my god I found
that book to be entirely terrifying but
the future could be bad well done good
book though it really made me a little
bit more pessimistic about society and
that's not necessarily something that I
want but it's really important that we
recognize that these kinds of things are
issues and then we live in a very
strange society if you don't know what
I'm talking about I suggest you go buy
feed buy MT Anderson it was very good I
got an email today from The Weather
Channel they would like to interview me
for a new show on global warming I'm the
kind of thing that I really expect
people to watch stupid there's always
something on I just want to know what
the weather is this stupid kids talking
that's kind of what I expect people to
be saying while I'm talking still very
cool you may have noticed that today's
video is a little late that is because
I'm in a forum it took me a while so
I've been doing that all day and a lot
of last night oh boy John your
challenges sometimes they wipe me out
and it's linked to on the sidebar or you
can just go straight to the forum with
that other Hutu calm slash my pants so
when there's a discussion in the
comments or maybe one of us is starting
a discussion in video format we can say
things like we'll continue this
discussion of John McCain in my pants
then you're not sure if the discussion
is going to happen in your pants or if
you're discussing John McCain in my
pants or if you're discussing John
McCain who is in my pants or if we're
just discussing it in the forum which is
called my pants it was one of my more
brilliant ideas and between you and me
that is saying something you will have
to register although that will probably
take you like 15 seconds it's not going
to replace the comments it'll be in
addition to the comments and you don't
have to go over there if you don't want
to but I'm fairly sure that some
interesting things will be going on
there's already a couple of discussion
threads there one in which I discussed
John McCain and lamented my saying what
I said and how I'm not ever actually
going to vote for John McCain sometimes
you just like to make your old brother
mad at you book book book but there's
also a thread about what to include in
the forum there are several sections and
several forums within sections and if
you think that there should be a section
or a forum please suggest it so that I
can create it and I'm very glad to have
that done with now I'm going to go eat
dinner and it's going to be great I will
see you tomorrow